hello on a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that and my guest
today is a remarkable man because he is
both a soldier and a scholar as well as
I can promise you much else besides and
here he is in person matias raag thank
you very much for joining us here today
on talking Germany hello thanking very
much for your invitation it's wonderful
wonderful to have you here now Colonel
Matthias rug to give him his military
rank is not just a soldier on active
duty in his capacity as a historian he
is also currently the director of the
military history museum in Dresden he's
a specialist field I ought to add is has
been the role of the military in German
society which is of course a fascinating
subject for discussion so a lot to talk
about and I'm very much looking forward
to it it's great to have a military man
here on the program and I'd like to
begin with the question what is it like
to be a military man in Germany I think
you can't compare with a military man
and in Britain or in France because are
a lot of people in German are what we
would call in German they've Z fremden
they are a little bit timid I think it
has yeah to do with her with our history
the history of the especially the Second
World War the Holocaust and everything
what deals with the question of power
and violence and that time and therefore
it was it was a very long way and it was
not so easy to find a position for a new
army after the Second World War we have
a broken tradition in our history and
also now millet especially in our
military history and therefore it was a
long run to to develop our German forces
are in the last 55 60 years ok we'll be
talking about all those abstract
questions that you've indicated their
bow just tell me about how do people
respond to you when you when you're out
on the street in your uniform as you are
today what is the response because you
said you said this use this word Z
frendall the Akita sort of a little bit
of a distance
yeah yeah sometimes they ask me perhaps
when I stay at at the airport or railway
station they asked me for the train or
if I they asked me for some information
because you see I we I will uniformly
must be no official perhaps the soldier
or a firefighter or or but but but not
especially an officer of the Bundeswehr
yeah and that means so the uniform of a
German officer is not so familiar for a
lot of people in Germany exactly you do
i mean when i see you here today in your
uniform the first thought that comes to
mind is that i haven't seen a military
uniform for I don't know weeks or months
that's quite unusual in other countries
you see people in uniform much more
regularly yeah yeah and therefore I will
the uniform at wherever I can because
yeah it's my working dress and the
people they yet they see who i am and
sometimes people ask me about the
Bundeswehr about military history about
politics or anything else because they
recognize me interesting you talked
about Germany's broken tradition from
outside Germany there's a lot of people
a lot of commentators who look at
Germany and they say it's a little bit
of a pacifist country is that are they
right to say that yeah I think they are
right um because um after the Second
World War a lot of people they had the
idea no war in future no army and we had
this long in Germany without us that
means owner owns not with us yeah and we
have a very very specific history and in
no other country we have all the history
or the tremendous experience with the
Holocaust and it has a lot of to do the
Holocaust with a military also with the
military and with people who were
uniforms yeah
and a lot of people they can't yeah well
or they don't see exactly or the candy
white were between SS or the way I
marked or or other weird uniform and
therefore I think it it is it is very
very complicated not not easy and as I
said there was a long time was necessary
to see that it is also possible for a
new tomography democracy to build up an
army and a completely new structure are
in a in with with lures with the
Constitution inside and an army which is
so involved in the structures of
democracy hmm let's talk about again
topics that we'll come back to a little
bit later let's just talk about you
personally for just a moment you are
both a scholar as I've mentioned under
soldier which came first I think first
one was a soldier I became an officer
cadet in 1983 and I started an ordinary
career as a tank officer and after eight
years of service I started oh my my
studying at University and yeah it was
not a common study because I at that
time it was not able to study history
and modern history at the University of
the Bundeswehr so I went to a turn
ordinary a wrestler universe a regular
University in freiburg and and after i
finished my my my university career with
my PhD then I wanted to link both the
military career armed the academic
career and perhaps that brought me to
the military museum I mean if that's
what you had set out to do that is
something that you've done very
successfully indeed I think it's fair to
say because since 2010 Colonel drug has
been the director of to give it its full
name the Bundys fair military history
museum in the
eastern german city of Dresden and a
year or so after he took over the museum
it reopened after it had been
reconstructed in grand style by the
often inspirational sometimes
controversial architect Daniel Libeskind
let's go on a tour of the building now
with Matthias rock like an arrowhead the
new structure cuts through the
neoclassical facade of the military
history museum in Dresden the thirty
meter wedge with a viewing platform
interrupts the former Arsenal symmetry
symbolizing a break with old traditions
the building has been a Saxon armory and
Museum a Nazi Museum and an East German
one now it offers a new look at the
history of the Armed Forces American
architect Daniel liebe c-can't has given
physical expression to the philosophy
behind the museum which is director
Matthias cog promotes to the public when
the museum was opened in 2011 the Army
Colonel led his guests through the
exhibition in person and in uniform of
course because the Bundys fear runs the
facility it's a modern museum that
doesn't see itself as a collection of
heroic battle paintings and weapons but
as a self critical look at the
instruments of war bombs and missiles
are shown as they are threatening and a
display of prosthetic arms and legs for
people wounded in war shows what they
can do the intention is to shock and be
thought provoking
this boy abunda spare cheap in a booby
trap in Afghanistan three German
soldiers in it were wounded it's an
exhibit that's personally important to
matthias hawk because instead of
military history it shows the here and
now even pacifists have their place here
this outfit from a demonstration is on
exhibition a parody of a uniform and
medals worn by Petrocelli the 1980s
peace activist and co-founder of
Germany's Green Party Matthias fog says
that too belongs in a military museum
even though he's been shaped by army
life since his childhood Matthias rock
was born in fitment in east frisia in
1963 his father was a professional
soldier he often took his son within
into the field the boy thought eating
with the troops was the greatest
Matthias hawk is still an enthusiastic
amateur cook and he hasn't given up
playing the guitar
he's been in the Bundeswehr since 1983
the colonel is a sensitive art lover who
paints in watercolors and is deeply
rooted in his Christian faith he often
enthusiastically discusses how that fits
with the life of a soldier laying
appointed director of the Bundeswehr
military history museum was like a gift
touareg who's also a history professor
he's interested in the relationship
between the military and society and he
can look into that now with every new
exhibition and today he's our guest on
talking Germany Colonel Matthias rock
and Colonel rob the museum interested
your museum is a remarkable building and
it's got this you know it's got this
thing cutting into the middle of it a
wedge orent the wets yeah you call it
away be care of the wedge yes it's a
little bit like an arrowhead or an axe
head or something like that what is it
what does it signify it stands for
violence and for power and the topic we
are dealing with in the museum and it
cuts through the old Arsenal like a cat
in our history yeah you see the German
history in the 20th century's full of
cats with two revolutions one in
nineteen eighty nineteen eighteen and
nineteen nineteen and the second
revolution are we are just remembering
25 years after we have two world wars
with a very prominent ya role of german
army in german politics and we have two
dictatorships one in the GDR and the
other in the in the NS regime and that
means a lot of cutting through through
our history through our tradition and
you can say it is symbolizing
architecture like an icon an
architecture yeah and an icon
architecture of the wedge and without
the wedge it wouldn't work the whole
system the whole idea of the museum
wouldn't work how important is it that
the museum is located in Dresden because
certainly the city of Dresden for people
outside Germany has a huge resonance and
that resonance is linked primarily to
the events at the end of the Second
World War it is very very prominent only
one side we have the big collection for
the military history museum since or 125
years ok it is so yeah like the basis
for the museum a collection of 1.1
million objects but are the history of
the city of the destroying of the city
and the Second World War
in the evening of the 13th of the
fifteenth of februari 1945 it is it is
very very important because a peak of
the wedge it shows exactly to the point
where the destruction of the city of the
destroying of the city and that night
started and the shape of the wedge is
exactly in the way were the where the
aeroplane started their attacks and and
it is more more or less exactly like the
shape of the destruction of the ancient
city of treason and therefore you have a
lot of breeches a lot of links from the
building and the architecture to the
history of the of the city and up to now
every year on the thirteenth of februari
people remember the destroying of the
city and I don't know any other city in
Germany or any other region were the war
violence and the destruction at the end
of the world is so much remember than
resonant by this it was so it was
logical consequence that any liebe
skinned or was looking for a strong link
to the history of the city it's
fascinating stuff it's quite abstract on
the other hand I know that for you it's
very important that your museum really
investigates the human component of war
yeah how war is experienced by
individual human beings I'm a little bit
about that yeah I'll actually in a
military history museum armory weapons
uniform signals flags they stand in the
center but we see our it's not enough
what we should be interested is human
yeah you and me yeah that means ordinary
persons man yeah and we focus on man the
man stands in the middle of the history
or of the story of our museum that mine
that means man as perpetrators
especially soldiers man or people as WIC
terms
and sometimes you don't have not only
perpetrators or Wickham's but also the
bystanders those who stand beside and
look at the scenery and what are they
doing in that triangle of these three
people of these three are point of views
we want to tell the story and it is much
more than a story of only of military
but of violence of the history of power
and violence and then we spread this
they seem and we see it is uh yeah in
some way a universal soldier a universal
a museum yeah what interests me is then
if we're talking about people is how
individual people respond because
certainly when I began first coming to
Germany you would talk about the
military experience as part of the human
experience and people would say I don't
need to talk about that I don't want to
talk about that war is bad that's the
end of the story there were very few
books about war very few films about
more very few poems about war which in
other countries would be much more
prominent in the dead be a public debate
going on that's only really begun to
start in Germany in recent years that's
my feeling at least yeah and I think
after the reunification um it started
and now we must say 20 25 years ago or
30 years ago military history was yeah
it is a colleague of mine he called a
douche Moodle Kent that means a little a
little child who saw playing in the mud
yeah yeah okay and no one was really
interested and some said why should we
teach military history at university but
the last 25 years are we had in some way
a revolution in the point of view of
military history because we think it is
we are so much involved in the questions
of power and violence and we have so
much suffered by the two world wars
especially by the by the last World War
not only by the separation of the two
countries and the cutting through by
there by the iron
button but all the by the bait fallen
with a consequence consequences yam the
consequences of the war that now we see
we have to look at the war we have to
look at military we have to look at
military history to know or to to
understand better why history came and
right or developed in that way i dunno
okay and when you do that what do you do
in your Museum with the fact that many
people outside Germany for so long
rightly or wrongly viewed Germany and
view to Germans as uniquely warlike as
uniquely aggressive yeah what do you do
with that perception that people have
heard of Germany in your Museum you can
only answer if you change the
perspective if you have a different
perspective on the same thing then you
have for the point where you can can can
take every people to see okay you have
your own experience you think we are
more or less a peaceful society or a
society of formal areas and we put them
from that point of view and we look on
the Thames sings the same story and then
you have to think about it because you
see the other story and you see that
there's no truth in history but a lot of
reality and that reality refers and I
think there's one of the points why we
have so much success because it is
sophisticated in one way yeah but it is
in special ways it's honest okay thank
you
a wall that changed the world a wall
that was like no other that went before
what do you say about this war and what
made it so so different from there from
what had gone before as a military man
yeah it is the first world war the first
war were the industrialization of the
mass mobilization our was so important
and for me in the center for me stem
stands in the center that d limitation
or the yeah the the the San interesting
words there there's a limitation
Association so the lifting listen
bishops yeah right by the production of
ammunition by the destruction by weapons
the invention by new weapons as gas or a
teller tillery was very very big
calibers with tanks with aeroplanes and
so on everything seems possible to be
invented to kill people and that this is
one of the most important point of views
for me the fragmentation of the society
yeah the upside down nothing after the
year after the war of the four for use a
war was when the war was when the war
started the upside down the
fragmentation of the job of the society
and also the casualties you mentioned 60
million of people we don't know exactly
but only only nine to 10 million
soldiers yeah the rest were civilians
and especially in the wintertime in
wintertime of 1962 1970 in the famous
so-called human ventura in germany where
line yeah there was nothing to eat in
germany and most of the people they they
only had carrots yeah or they were
reaching roots roots yeah quite
literally root crop effectively and we
don't know exactly but it seems that 700
to 750 thousand civilians died they by
starvation well tell me this way I know
what your museum
got an exhibition I think it's beginning
on the first of August yes August which
is nineteen fourteen twenty forty the
hundred year anniversary using the
figure 14 and then taking 14 biographies
again to get the sort of give us a human
approach to this immense catastrophe
give me an example of one of the
biographies and how it could be
instructive for us first of all of all I
want to say that we are partner in a
cooperation or with arta and other TV
stations they produce are or they made
of production are called 14 diaries of
the First World War and these 14
biographies you stand on a focus of the
film production you will find in our
exhibition and one is for example an
sooner and sooner was a young man a
writer writer and a lot of people they
know him by his famous novel in style
give it and he was a hero and he wrote
in a run in a heroic way he will see his
walking stick it is it is so ridiculous
to take a walking stick when you when
you when you launch an attack yeah but
he took this walking stick with him to
see I'm a gentleman and it's a it's not
only fighting it's not only struggle but
it's only a little bit of my ya like
like walking like a gentleman through
the war and there's something farcical
about it I think yeah you'll be the word
on the one side it is ridiculous on
there on the other side you see it it's
up it is unbelievable it's completely
throwing out of out of our time and I
think with these biographies you can see
on one side the war is very very near to
us because of the people of their
biographies of their characters who in
sometimes they are very very modern and
on the other side it is 100 years ago
that means three generations yeah I was
going to ask you because it is it is
interesting there are lots and lots of
exhibitions all over Europe at this
point I'm a lot of
divisions in Germany I think more than
80 exhibitions yeah on the First World
War what what do we learn though by
comparing you know 1914 with 2014 what's
the immediate contemporary relevance the
relevance is that the First World War
the Second World War belong together
there is a bridge between them a lot of
historians they speak about the second
30s Years War or the big civilian War of
the European civilian war in the in the
20th century and that means if you want
to understand or to want to know much
more about the Second World War you have
to learn the first because after the
Treaty of Versailles nothing was good
and we had we have such a fragmentation
in Europe after the declining of the big
empires Russia and are the Ottoman
Empire and the problems of the decline
of these empires are we we focus up to
now if you look at the Near East or if
you look at the Vulcan or if you look at
the rims of the former Soviet Union and
the struggle between the neighbors not
only in the Ukraine and so on all these
struggles all these problems began with
and short after the First World War and
that means if you want to learn a little
bit more about the 20th century to
understand why the 20th century is such
an area in our history of of violence
yeah you have to know much more bothers
first workable okay talking about
violence let's talk again once again did
this whole notion of German militarism
because there's a there's the ongoing
debate about who was to blame who
started the first World War and we can't
go there now we just don't have time we
would need two hours to begin to discuss
it but German militarism takes a lot of
the blame what's the difference between
the German military then and the German
military now
haha it is like to compare or living on
earth when living on the Mars it's
completely different um the military in
and before the First World War it stand
at the the peak of the column but means
uh they were the best of the society and
everything in the society it focused on
the military the military class and are
ya and now the military stands in the
middle of the society it is involved are
there is a critical society that looks
on the military and it is not yeah you
you can see we we are not better than
other people and I think that's you can
say it's completely different one word
that we haven't spoken about in it
suddenly occurs to me I really would
like to hear your viewer list we've
talked about militarism we've talked
about combat we've talked about it being
an aspect of the human experience and
its relevance we haven't mentioned the
word two words heroes and heroism how
relevant today or not to your personal
military vocabulary I think we we also
have been present we have efefef heroes
yeah perhaps if you could look at sports
man and also and militarily of heroes
but in completely other way a hero for
me is a self-standing person who does
his duty and who does this desis duty
not for himself but for other perhaps
who serve for his country and a hero in
former times perhaps in the First World
War if you if you look at the Second
World War he was a hero because he did a
very good job as a military leader or
that he is a brave man yeah brief is
necessary but brave doesn't only mean
arm to to use your weapon and to to
launch an attack but brave
in a much more sophisticated way
the fundamental problem here what we're
talking about for the Bundeswehr at this
point in time is it's in a transition
from being a conscription army to being
a fully professional force like in many
other countries yeah and it's not so
easy because a lot of the later
professional soldiers ngos and offices
they came to the Bundeswehr first by
conscription a.m. and then they saw ok r
it is the Bundeswehr isn't in a little
bit it is another army then I then I
thought yeah and now they are interested
and they start a career and talking of
Korea's I want to go in there because
they would be till we were looking at
schools we're talking about about
recruiting I have we were just talking
about our children while we're watching
that report we've got children at the
same sort of age my children have left
school but they haven't chosen a career
yet tell me why they should join the
Bundys fear the Bundeswehr is very
interesting for people who are not sure
what should be the direction of my
profession in the next year's um you
will find yourself you will you will get
a lot of inspiration by other x by x
over x by you or by your superiors yeah
and we have a lot of possibilities for
development and I think you start you do
your job and then you see other careers
and other possibilities to to find a way
for you own and and therefore it is a
very very good experience for you for
the first one or three or two years um
when you when you are not sure you've
got a lot of money we heard in that
report that we've just been watching the
for advertising for the by discarding
yeah yeah for the promotional campaign
yeah you don't pay very well no I'm glad
you admit it yeah that's a problem yeah
it's a problem and but you must see the
society must see in the German society
that
they need money for the army there's no
discussion in Great Britain hmm but you
have sometimes you have the same
problems yeah not only by looking for
the offices for the higher ranks they
are very very well paid hmm but for for
for the privates for those that we call
the ordinary soldier ordinary soldiers
what we call the engines yeah it's not
the chief Gaines okay yeah so there's
that problem and I'm glad d I'm glad you
have admitted to it there's another
fundamental problem that the German
armed forces have now is that it I guess
at the time when you signed out that was
back in nineteen eighty-three 1983 okay
at that time there was no real chance of
you being sent into a rear sort of
shooting and being shot at situation
mission now being in the Bundeswehr is
dangerous yeah and it shows you now what
it means to be a soldier that it could
mean to shoot at another person to kill
some other and also to be killed and
that is completely different to any
other profession you will have
especially if if you look at policeman
or firefighter it's completely different
and that's completely new for us yeah
new experience and also are the long
distances oh when we stay in mission for
months perhaps four years yeah uh it's
it's tremendous for families yeah okay
we've talked about the dangers there
that's important that we have done I
think let's talk about something a
little bit more piece like talk about
one of your many pastimes I know you
like cooking I know you like playing the
guitar and you like painting watercolors
good love it yeah you should we start
with that one across there okay look
have we got that a bit ly ya gon tell me
you tell me what that's all about yeah
it is hell on one of my favourite
islands and I did this picture of this
watercolor from the ship when we left
when we left Hal Verlander hot oh I had
only I think 20 25 minutes and you have
and you could keep a steady hand on
board the boat
to paint very very fast yeah and the
perspective is changing yeah and it
works so it doesn't work well I think it
did work why did why did you how did you
come to painting and water painting in
the first place so did you learn it from
who inspired you um I I was interested
in arts and Fine Arts since I was saw in
school yeah but I started in painting by
myself i started in 1991 yeah my wife
she said oh no it's it's so it's so
boring always when you have a free time
you go to a museum or you read a book
try another thing you have you have such
a good skill in in making sketches and
watercolors and then I started and I've
made the experience that is wonderful
you are in a completely other world
here's another one we've just got time
for one more of your wonderful
watercolors and I particularly like this
one because we talked about the city of
Dresden this race is only a very very
fast sketch I think I did it in 10
minutes yeah it's the water but it's
like a snapshot it's yeah yeah the
revising and this shows us what survived
of the city after the bombing the water
was rebuilt at the destruction what
survived what was rebuilt yeah most of
most are far off the building's you see
are a very build yeah the Opera lovely
paintings yeah thank you very much for
bringing them along great stuff now
we're at the end of the show we like to
do a short quiz yeah where I gives you
internet ifs yeah here we go uh oh I can
hear the music our human beings
naturally peaceful or naturally
aggressive
they are naturally peaceful we're gonna
leave it there I'm very peaceful would
have any time for any other questions
but he has been a wonderful guest a very
compelling guest Matthias the wrong
colonel Matthias raag if you've enjoyed
his company as much as I have then come
back next week bye bye aunt Electress